you
hello and welcome to 2012 US
Championships here in st. Louis I'm
Jennifer chehade and this is Mike line
and after five rounds we have had some
really thrilling action here so many
decisive games at this level of
competition usually there's a lot more
drawers but in particular white has been
racking up number of wins that's right
one of the most surprising ones was 52
year old Gregory Cardona off the senior
statesman in the event winning with
white against gata kamsky the defending
champion this ends gotta calm skis 51
game unbeaten streak which is the second
longest in all of us championship
history hadaan off got a very big
opening advantage gotta miss played the
move order and the past a pawn had to be
blockaded by God as best pieces clean
and that rendered his army pretty
ineffective never a good time now this
helped pave the way for world number
seven and st. Louis's own Hikaru
Nakamura to take the clear lead in the
US Championship he won a number of
impressive games including a beautiful
dragon on the white side against Bray
Robson yeah definitely I Carl did his
homework in this game he saw that Robson
had played the dragon in the aeroflot
open copied a lot of the same moves and
took an advantage to the endgame it got
a little dicey his King had to walk up
to the 6th rank but as is very often the
case a knight's shield to King from
Queen checks very beautiful great game
even had forever marked on Twitter that
he loved this game he called a kumar's
15 years a little bit in round five
against Ivanov and playing his usual d
for this was a very nice positional
grind
he ended up with this beautiful
breakthrough 61 f 5 kind of couldn't
really take with either pond so he had
to allow nakamura spawn to f6 then
Hikaru got his King all the way into e7
and put Kai Donovan a beautiful Zoe's
law so some really impressive play by
our top seed in this tournament and that
leaves him half a point ahead of his
main rival defending champion gata
kamsky that's right over in the women's
event arenas eniac is the surprise
leader she only scored two points at the
2011 US Women's Championship she already
earned more than that through three
rounds of play she took a relatively
equal end game where she had night
versus bishop and she was able to quite
surprisingly ensnare tatev Abraham ians
bishop by playing 57g for she walked
over with her King and snared the bishop
and earned the point and she's also
getting a PhD in environmental science
from Carnegie Mellon what's a secret to
her success I don't know she finds a
time all the players praise her work
ethic a lot of them during the free day
went to the zoo went and did some
shopping she said she spent seven hours
preparing for her game today against
Irina Krush enlisting the help of three
grand masters and she ended up drawing
that game and that leaves us with the
three-way tie for the lead in the US
Women's Championship besides nu we have
the usual suspects defending champion on
its accounts eat and Irene across the
action is only getting more heated here
in st. Louis so join us either in person
at the beautiful chest covenants classic
center of st. Louis at one o'clock local
time or at to Eastern on us chest champs
calm
you